good morning my name is David Bob I
serve as director of the LNP Kirby jr.
center for constitutional studies and
citizenship Hillsdale College has been
in Washington DC doing this program this
lecture series since december of 2008
we're delighted this morning to have
joining us from the University of
nevada-reno John marini professor marini
is no stranger to Washington and in a
minute one of our whip students a
student who's part of the Washington
Hillsdale internship program will give
them a proper introduction but the topic
today is very important for we've heard
recently a swirl of of conversation
about whether in fact the institution of
Congress is broken most of it if you if
you follow especially what the news
media has been reporting focuses on
questions of process it's the filibuster
to blame are there other factors at work
and the thesis that Professor marini has
it been advancing not just for four
months but really for four years and
indeed going back two decades has been
the same and that is that any of the the
cyclical grievances that we find lodged
against Congress can be explained by
something called the administrative
state he's going to tell us a little bit
about what all of that means later and
we'll leave lots of time as usual for
your questions I wanted to make just a
couple of brief announcements before we
do begin this morning that is the
Hillsdale has just published our first
white paper it's out online and also
with a few copies on the table there
some of you may have been present for
the remarks that sparked that
the production of this white paper
Justice Stephen markman has for about 17
years now taught constitutional law at
Hillsdale College he sits on Michigan's
highest court the Supreme Court and has
been looking at issues for a number of
years that he believes are going to be
at the forefront of our coming
constitutional debate in 1988 Justice
markman then with the Reagan
administration and the Justice
Department wrote a report for attorney
general ed Meese incidentally Attorney
General nice will be giving hillsdale's
158 commencement address tomorrow about
2pm so it's something that I growing out
of that then was a report done sort of
on the opposite side of the legal
Academy and this was a report that was
issued in book form it's called the
Constitution in 2020 Justice markman
responds to to those legal scholars by
saying that their vision for the
Constitution would really mean that
judges not people through their elected
representatives were rule so you can
find out more information about that
online at our website Justice markman is
also the featured in Primus we're happy
that I from campus the editor of an
Primus and the vice president for
external affairs Jeffrey can join us
today the rest of campus is is busily
preparing turning in those grades and
reading for for the big day tomorrow so
that means also that our whipped
students are heading out Washington
Hillsdale internship program has been
around for about 35 years if any of you
work at places where you'd like to have
interns like to have Hillsdale students
please see me or Jennifer Powell we'd
love to to place interns will have
probably about 30 students here this
summer and with the opening of the the
Hillsdale building just across the
street from here in the fall I hope that
during the academic term will also be
able to have a robust number of students
Jason Statler is a rising senior he this
semester
a major in political science has been
able to see the fine art of lobbying
while working at the American Trucking
Association so taken with Washington but
we hope not given to bouts of Potomac
fever he will stay on this summer and
work at a place called the American
Highway users association so Jason is
going to introduce our speaker this
morning one John marini is professor of
political science at the University of
Nevada Reno where he has been on the
faculty since 1988 a senior fellow at
the claremont institute and a member of
the nevada advisory committee of the u.s
Civil Rights Commission Roy knee surg
from 1987 to 1988 as a special assistant
to Clarence Thomas who was then chairman
of the United States Equal Employment
Opportunity Commission he received his
BA from san jose state university in his
PhD in government from claremont
graduate school published widely he is
the author of the politics of budget
control Congress the presidency and the
growth of the administrative state and
the Imperial Congress crisis in the
separation of powers please join me in
welcoming John marina oh thank you it's
nice to be here I was asked to speak on
the question these Congress broken the
short answer is yes for one very
fundamental reason Congress no longer
fulfills its constitutional purpose I
think that sums it up thank you
but there is a longer more detailed
answer to that question the Constitution
established a limited national
government one intended to preserve the
autonomy of civil society and the
integrity of a federal system Congress
was meant to be the central political
institution in a system of separated
powers that dependent upon each
political branch fulfilling its
constitutional role but in the history
of the 20th century was one of
relentless aggrandizement and
centralization of national governmental
and administrative power the presidency
and we have to say of both parties going
back to the beginning of the century
Teddy Roosevelt Woodrow Wilson FDR and
even Dwight Eisenhower you might not
think as a centralizer was actually
president when the Department of Health
Education and Welfare was created they
all sought to centralize power in the
national government but for much of the
20th century Congress resisted it
remained a decentralising force within
the federal system it served to defend
the powers and autonomy of state and
local governments as well as civil
society the reorganization of Congress
after 1965 is pivotal to understanding
the manner in which constitutional
government came to be undermined by the
rise in growth of the administrative
state as i said the central
institutional feature of the
constitution is separation of powers it
was when it functioned properly the
obstacle that stood in the way of a
fundamental transformation of the
national government from one of limited
power to one of unlimited power and
scope that transformation of the
institution of the American government
came about as a result of a gradual
change in opinion concerning the meaning
and purpose of constitutional government
which began in the progressive year the
leaders of the progressive movement were
hostile to the constitution there were
implacable enemies of the doctrine of
separation of powers whereas the
Constitution embodied a political
philosophy which required limitation on
the power of government the progressives
were animated by a theory of the state
which required unlimited state power
indeed the progressive believed that the
fundamental purpose of the modern state
is the effective implementation of
majority will which is articulated by
the political leadership and carried out
by technically trained bureaucracy the
progressives knew that the Constitution
in defending individual rights had not
established the ground of moral
legitimacy and will not the will of
majorities minorities or any branch of
government the ground of morality was
established by nature itself understood
through reason Constitution was meant to
establish a rational structure of
governance that prevented domination of
will especially irrational will
consequently it is government itself
when understood is a reflection on human
nature that made the separation of
powers and necessity powers of an
encroaching nature so ambition must be
made to counteract ambition consequently
it is necessary to balance the executive
and legislative branches as institutions
with specific virtues against each other
the virtue of the legislative body lay
in its capacity to represent
constituencies and through deliberation
and lawmaking reconcile diverse
interests while seeking a common good
the virtues of the executive were
primarily administrative virtues the
capacity to act with energy secrecy and
dispatch the virtue of the judiciary
rested upon the ability of the courts to
cultivate good judgment which required
independence from the political branches
in Federalist number 70 Alexander
Hamilton expressed the prevailing view
of how it was thought the political
branches ought to be
student he wrote those politicians and
statesmen who have been most celebrated
or the soundness of their principles and
for the Justice of their views have
declared in favor of a single executive
and a numerous legislature they have
considered energy is the most necessary
qualification of the former and have
regarded this as most applicable to
power in a single hand while they have
with equal propriety considered the
latter is best adapted to deliberation
and wisdom and that's calculated to
conciliate the confidence of the people
and to secure their privileges and
interest end of quote the purpose of
separation of powers was to allow each
branch to participate in establishing
the common good in disputes between the
branches this is not the will of
Congress the president or the courts but
the reason of the constitutional
afforded it which ought to prevail the
rejection of nature and reason is the
standard for political life grew out of
the acceptance among intellectuals of a
philosophy of history history itself if
we believe Hagel was thought to be a
rational process which culminated in the
idea of the state the rational or
administrative state was to be the
vehicle for the administration of
progress it signified the end of being
full history at an end of meaningful
politics it us ushered in a new age
which would require require the rule of
knowledge or expertise the leaders of
progressivism who mobilize those
theories as a political movement cepted
the view that the state is an ethical
and irrational organization the state
was thought to be the rational
embodiment of the changing or
progressive will of the people hence the
government of the state could not be
perceived as a danger to the people's
liberties rather the state would provide
the opportunity for the expansion of
freedom understood progressively
consequently once history has arrived at
its last stage of development the
Democratic foremost
Society the checks upon the power of
government are not only unnecessary but
pernicious the remaining tasks of
government are primarily administrative
and requiring the rule of organized
intelligence as a result progressive
intellectuals like Woodrow Wilson
insisted that the real source of power
in the modern state is in the
administrative realm it is necessary to
establish an administrative bureaucracy
in order to generate the requisite
technical knowledge required to solve
every human problem if the purpose of
government is to solve every problem the
power of government must be unlimited
for Wilson the distinction between
politics and administration would
replace the fundamental separation of
powers established by the Constitution
and the new progressive order politics
would still require the political
branches to establish the will of
majority through elections but the
administrative bureaucracy armed with
the expertise generated in the
university would carry out that will in
an ironic reversal of the constitutional
order the people even their
representatives are required to give up
their reason in order to allow a
scientifically rational bureaucracy
scientifically trained rational
bureaucracy to carry out their will the
Prudential principal separation of
powers like the principal like the
Constitution itself was thought to be an
historical anachronism in the final
analysis it is not the Constitution but
the will of the progressive majority
which has come to be regarded as the
only source of legitimacy and democratic
politics prior to the growth of the
administrative state the general
interests of government could be
articulated and partisan compromises
could be accommodated within the
political branches this was so because
the administrative functions of the
national government were few as were the
organized constituencies alive allied to
those functions after the centralization
of administration the operation and
interests of the executive and
legislative branches were
mentally transform the role of the
parties was also diminished because
bureaucratic patronage would become more
important than party patron in addition
the role of the judiciary would also be
transformed the bureaucracy has no
constitutional authority but it was
given enormous power by the political
branches in the administrative state the
courts have been required to enter the
policy-making process as the final
arbiters in the adjudication of cases
arising in the administrative process
some political observers could see the
direction that centralization of
administration was taking in 1964 Ronald
Reagan was already convinced that the
continued growth of centralization of
administration would lead to tyranny and
the loss of freedom in his famous speech
called a time for choosing given on
behalf of Barry Goldwater he noted and I
quote now it doesn't require
expropriation or confiscation of private
property or business to impose socialism
out of people what does it matter
whether you hold the deed or the title
to your business or property if the
government holds the power of life and
death over that business or property
such machinery already exists the
government can find some charge to bring
against any concern it chooses to
prosecute every businessman has his own
tale of harassment somewhere the
perversion has taken place our natural
inalienable rights are now considered to
be distance against a dispensation of
government and freedom has never been so
fragile so close to slipping from our
dress as it is at this moment end of
Reagan's quote in that speech Reagan
made it clear let's centralized control
of the economy and society by the
federal government could not be done
without undermining individual rights
and establishing coercive and des body
control he noted in this next quote the
full power of centralized government
this was the very thing the founding
father sought to minimize
they knew that governments don't control
things a government can't control the
economy without controlling people and
they knew that when a government sets
out to do it that it must use force and
coercion to achieve its purpose they
also knew those founding fathers that
outside of its legitimate functions
government does nothing as well or as
economically as the private sector of
the economy end of that quote a Reagan
had reason to be fearful of the future
as regards administrative centralization
nonetheless 1965 a year after Reagan's
speech Samuel Huntington famous Harvard
political scientists noted that Congress
was still a DD centralized institution
which represented parochial and state
interests could not function well within
the context of the burgeoning
administrative state consequently make
the Huntington pointed out the
presidency had become the dominant force
in American national politics and he
observed and I'm quoting today's
aggressive spirit is clearly the
executive branch this is 1965 the loss
of power he suggested and I quote again
can be measured by the extent to which
congressional assertion coincides with
congressional obstruction this paradox
has been at the root of the problem of
Congress since the early days of the New
Deal visa V the executive Congress is an
autonomous legislative body but
apparently Congress can defend its
autonomy only by refusing to legislate
and it can legislate only by
surrendering in saytana me Congress can
insert can assert his powers or it can
pass laws but it cannot do both and
quote Huntington but there was another
option Congress could adapt itself to
the requirements of an administrative
state it could give up the power to
legislate to administrative and
regulatory body and it could retain its
autonomy by becoming an oversight body
in short that's what happened and it
became the keystone
the washington established it may seem
surprising but until the Middle's of
middle of the 60s the american regime
was centrally government governing
excuse me and it was still
administrative ly decentralized the
presidency and even the parties had been
centralizing forces in American politics
through a much of the century but
Congress still concerned itself
primarily with the broad and general
interests of the nation and it functions
still as a deliberative and represented
representative lawmaking body private or
specialized interests were brokered in
the economic marketplace or administered
at the state and local level of
government even as late as 1964 there
was not much of a lobbying effort in in
the national capital of washington by
most major organizations economic social
religious it's inconceivable now that
any organization it does not have a
presence in washing a lobbying presence
now in the period between 65 and 75
Congress created a bureaucracy capable
essentially administering nearly all of
the details of American life it
attempted to solve not only the
political problems of the nation but the
social and economic problems of all
Americans as well at that time many in
Congress objected to the fact that the
political function of Congress is a body
was changed by its increased
preoccupation with the administrative
process represented gillis long
expressed the typical complaint and I
quote from him we Congress returning
ours from an institution that was
supposed to be a broad policymaking
institution with respect to the problems
of the country and its relationship into
the world into a merely a city council
that overlooks the running of the store
every day and quote objections such as
those expressed by long were
ineffectually short-lived after a few
years of experienced members of Congress
came to prefer administration and
regular
to deliberation and legislation
representative Jamie wit with Jamie
Witten summed up the view of many in
Congress at that time in an unusually
clear way he said and I quote the
smartest thing we ever did was to throw
the weight of the federal government
behind local problems end quote how did
Congress transform itself to accommodate
this new condition one rich reflected
the reality of administrative supremacy
in order to compete effectively with the
president Congress had to gain control
and subsequently expand the powers of
the bureaucracy in order to do so
Congress had to reorganize itself it did
so in a wave of reforms in the early and
middle 70s at first the reforms served
to decrease the power of the leadership
primarily that of the committee chairs
it increased power of individual members
by placing subcommittee jurisdiction
assignments chairmanships and a minimum
number of staff positions outside the
control of full committee chairs in
addition the staff of Congress itself
would become a major professionalised
bureaucracy the result was that these
institution gave up the capacity to
function as a deliberative and lawmaking
body but individual members of Congress
were able to utilize professional sat
staff to serve personal and constituency
goals even if the interest of the party
institution in the nation itself were
sometimes in conflict with those
individual interests the reforms of
Congress were defended on the grounds
that the institution was becoming more
open and democratic but the dispersal of
power to individual members did not
result in greater capacity to attain
national or even institutional goals
became much more lead difficult for the
leadership of the parties to persuade
members to act in a party national
interest as one observer put it at the
time the autocracy of the chair broken
Congress was transformed from an
institution in which power was closely
held by a few to an institution in which
almost everyone had
enough strength to toss a monkey wrench
in 1964 there were 47 meaningful
chairmanships available in the House and
Senate by 1984 there were 326 allowing
for those who hold more than one
chairmanship 202 of Congress is 235
members thirty-eight percent were in
charge of something at that time that's
something really involved the ability of
the legislators to intervene in policy
areas controlled by the rulemaking
bureaucracy by 75 the characteristic
activity of the federal government and
the legislature had become the
regulation or the administration of the
details of the social political and
economic life of the nation such a
development could not but strengthen the
organized interest and their ties to the
legislature at the expense of unified
control of the details of the event of
administration by the execu in the most
sympathetic observe of congressional
power did not fail to notice the change
James sunquest wrote at that time as
members become managers of professional
staffs the Chamber's disintegrate is
deliberative bodies in the traditional
sense of legislatures engaged in direct
interchange of views leading to a group
decision with each passing year the
House and Senate appear less as
collective institutions and more as
collections of institutions individual
staff group individual members staff
groups organized as offices and
subcommittees it is important to
understand the political significance of
the transformation of the legislature it
allowed individual members the ability
to enhance personal path by indirect
control or oversight of the federal
bureaucracy consequently the attention
to specific needs of interested
constituents decided at the center in
Washington would become the primary
concern of the legislative branch
there's no wonder that the
characteristic activity of government
was no longer general legislation made
by the
representatives of the people rather
administrative rules formulated by
technical experts were necessary for the
regulation of the smallest details of
life in society perhaps the most
striking change in American politics one
still not well understood i think is the
change that has occurred in the
characteristic activity of the two
political branches of government in his
constitutional origins eck yuta branch
was to be characterized by its capacity
to act energetic in the execution and
administration of the laws on the other
hand the responsibilities given to the
legislative body were primarily
deliberative with the view that
compromise would result could result in
consent consensus when passing
legislation the powers of Congress which
included the power to tax and spend as
well as oversight of the executive but
the legislative powers were thought to
be fundamentally different from those of
execution or administration the laws
were thought to specify the general
conditions under which departments and
agencies ought to operate Congress would
function as a body and its laws would be
general and operate equally on the whole
of society including those who make the
laws now you might object that the
Congress still makes laws for example
the recent health reform bill but I
think you will see that this that is not
a law in the constitutional sense it
only makes sense within the context of
an administrative state indeed it was
passed as a reconciliation measure a
procedure which grew out of the
Congressional Budget impoundment Control
Act of 1974 that act was intended to
make Congress a major player in the
administrative process by gaining
control over the details and aggregates
of the executive budget by a single vote
on on spending as you know the health
reform bill was almost 2,500 pages long
but it was not a law it provided it
provided the legal requirements
necessary to enable the admit
straight of apparatus the ability to
formulate the rules which govern health
care the law of 2500 pages will turn
into regular two rules of thousands and
thousands of pages it is a work in
progress in other words Charles Kessler
who's the editor of The Claremont Review
of Books I think caught the spirit of
what Congress was doing in her in his
edit his recent editorial saw this quote
from his editorial he says when our
founders thought about the law they
often thought along the lines of John
Locke who described law as a communities
settled standing rules in different and
the same to all parties emphasizing that
to be legitimate a statute must be
received and allowed by common consent
to be the rightful standard of right and
wrong and the common measure to decide
all controversies that's a quote from
locked between citizens this phone sighs
law this is Charles would control a
sixth of the US economy this phone sighs
law that would control the sixth of the
US economy cannot be a law by that
definition if you rummage through the
text of say the House of Representatives
version of the bill you will find scores
of places where power is delegated to
administrative agencies and special
boards which are charged to fill the
gaps in the written legislation by
promulgating thousands if not tens of
thousands of new pages of regulations
that will then be applied to individual
cases voters sometimes complained that
legislators don't read the laws they
enact why should they in this case this
is still true you could read this
Leviathan until your eyeballs popped out
and still not find any settled standing
rules or a meaning that is indifferent
in the same to all parties in fact it's
the point that's the point of such
promiscuous laws they operate not by
setting up fences to protect each man's
Liberty they start not from equal rights
but from equal and offer often unequal
privileges the favors or menace
that government may be stuck may bestow
on or withhold from its clients the
whole point is to empower governmental
officials usually unelected and
unaccountable bureaucrats to bless or
curse your petition as they see fit
guided of course by their expertise in a
law so fast so intricate and so
capricious that it could justify a
hundred different outcomes in the same
case faster than one might think the
government of equal laws turns into a
regime of arbitrary privileges and this
is still charlet a privilege is
literally a private law when the law
ceases to be a common standard of right
and wrong and a common measure to decide
to decide all controversy then the rule
of law ceases to be a Republican and
becomes the spotting freedom itself
ceases to be a right and becomes a gift
or a fruit of the corrupt bargain
because in such degraded regimes as
those who are close to and connected
with the ruling class have special
privileges and quote and it's just in a
certain way a confirmation of what
Reagan had feared in 1964 now this
extension of governmental power i think
is compatible with the administrative
state but it cannot be understood to be
within the letter or spirit of
constitutional government let me
conclude by suggesting that the
administrative state grew dramatically
in the last third of the 20th century
particularly with the reorganization of
Congress and it continues to expand even
to today but despite its expansion under
both parties it has not attained
legitimacy within the American
constitutional order it has only
provoked an ongoing debate within the
parties concerning the desirability of
expansion limitation or perhaps someday
diminution of the size and scope of the
federal government it seems that modern
democratic societies have all attempted
to central
why's power in administrative States but
they are faced with the apparent paradox
being less able to govern effectively
the more they try to administer the
political social and economic details of
life in society that's the really thank
you on Wednesday morning senator DeMint
giving a talk and he said that what has
happened in Congress is the main
priority of each legislature is how much
he can bring back to this constituency
at his state in his area by earmarks
yeah and that the inability to square of
earmarks was one of the real problems I
think that dovetails in a more specific
way with what you've been saying and i'd
like to hear you're short your comment
yeah i think there's no question that
that's that's the that's the thought to
be what the legislators role is once you
centralize power in Washington the
state's really a sovereign entities
don't exist their sovereign edit the
state's themselves are lobbyists to wash
me you have the National Association of
Governors the National Association of
Mayors the National Association state
legislature state legislators I mean the
whole point is once you centralize
there's no autonomous power within the
state and so the congressman's role in
even the Senate's role the Senators role
is how to get sick of the the assets
from the center back to the periphery I
mean that's that's really what they
think their role is and and so they're
the only reason to go back to the state
is is of course to
keep the stain informed and to inform
them of went of what it is you bring
them to get reelected and of course you
get bed that helps them get reelected
and when you look at and when you look
at that period after the
institutionalization of the
administrative state and once the role
of the congressman changed from one of
lawmaking it avoided the necessity on
the part of the congressman to have to
make controversial decisions which
expose that to two electoral defeat and
the incumbency then in the from the
periods the 70s all the way up to our
time and come as he is not as it's not a
reliable is it an indicator as it used
to be but when you think of the powers
of each incumbent congressman in terms
of the assets they have and in terms of
much of the bureaucracies created to
service the needs of constituencies that
have been created by the bureaucracy
that Congress created itself so Congress
gets credit for healthy their
constituents with bureaucracy but they
don't get the blame for having created
of your honor so it's it's a matter of
when you think about the legislative
branch well when you think of a
legislature like the United States
legislature it first since at least the
mid 60s it really doesn't function as a
pod if function almost I mean my senator
Reed from Nevada his stab his staff is
basically persist without his staff his
staff is larger than the staff of the
presidency probably up till the
Roosevelt presence before the creation
of the executive office of the
presidency presidents didn't have staffs
of that side now any any car any senator
birth particularly senator from a large
States going to have large staffs and
all they have offices in their districts
that they staff I mean when you think of
the it really is a body of many
executives over certain policy arena and
so it's very difficult to get agreement
on bigger questions and this opens up
the possibility i think this health
reform bill because it does in a sense
nationalizing the life the elect the
election regardless of the intention of
that and it one thing that changed in
this bill that when you look back at the
various other reforms that were
significant weather during the even the
New Deal Social Security or the Great
Society there was not such clear stark
division between the parties usually
there was bipartisan support from those
those nation this time you get really
stark clarity about this this bill that
opens up the possibility of course if
the Republicans are clever and how they
use of mobilizing that sentiment and
nationalizing an election and perhaps
obscuring the advantage that incumbents
have in the electoral process because
when you think about these bandages
they've given to themselves and campaign
finance reform too by the way I mean
every political science study shows that
what campaign finance reform does is
limit the possibility of challenges and
so it becomes very very difficult to
defeat the income and both parties have
participated right must not think that
this was just simply a democratic proper
and in fact whenever a president who was
opposed to the centralization of
administration ran into opposition from
his own party if he was a Republican
whether it was Reagan and even Nixon
before if you take Nixon second term as
an example where Nixon really was
starting out in a very different way as
opposed to what he was planning to do
after 72 but I think there's no question
that that that that decentralizing
element that Congress still maintained
where their ties to their states and
their concerns for protecting their
autonomy of the state doesn't exist
anymore and I'm not so sure that state
legislatures and governors wanted they
just want money I don't know that they
want out I'm not clear they weren't
sovereigns so there was a populist room
of the led to the 17th amendment yep can
you discuss that how they convinced the
Senators to to sign off on their own
reestablishment des agents of the people
instead of agents of the states yeah
well that's part of all of those
progressive reforms as I said at the
beginning of my paper that that for for
the progressives you wanted unimpeded
majority with and the will of the people
with has to be established in the
legislative branch not the will of this
not the possibility that the Senators
represent States because the states as
when state legislatures state
legislatures actually picked senators
they did so of course with the view that
the Senate least the mid that they chose
would be best representative of the
state interests as well and so that was
a decentralizing effect it kept the
kept the state's active and by the way
that's one provision of the Constitution
you know that is on a mendham that you
can't deprive a state of its
representation in the Senate without its
consent so the founders thought that to
be fundamentally important keeping the
sovereignty of those states because they
wanted power they wanted administration
to be decentralized they did not want
every decision about the country that we
made that one play in in one place but
in a sense that's what really what
happened with the centralization of
administration is every important
decision on any question is made in
Washington and so everybody becomes a
petition every every local and state
government every kind of National
Association and even if you're even if
you're not I noticed with my hotel
across the street was the national
association of realtors I mean even if
you're a you know any kind of activity
requires a specialized effort at logging
that requires a national presence and
this is true now not only of economic
interest of social interest my
university itself has a lobbyist year
every University every I even religions
petition and Lobby Washington now if
that's not an centralized administrative
state it's very close and we're not as
far along as some states by the way I
mean the Constitution still does
function in some ways it does become
possible periodically for leadership to
arise as Ronald Reagan said in 1980
mobilize a constituency around the
sentiment that government is not the
solution to our problem government is
the problem I mean now you can always do
that and that's what the separation of
powers was meant to do is to create and
mobilize different constituencies the
president's can
did you indeed are different than the
constituencies that are created in the
States and in the locality so I think
it's it is always possible but it
correct it requires leadership and I
think what is lacking in both parties is
leaders who understand what this problem
because once you're a part of the
Washington establishment you're blind to
the proper it's very difficult to see it
when you're here because you know it
operates in a certain way and people get
used to it operating in that way and and
of course let's face it many of you may
work as staffers in Congress you got
your degrees at these universities by
the way these universities themselves
were created to provide the knowledge
for the administrative state in the
thought of Hegel in hegel's thought the
rationale in organized intelligence that
is going to that is going to be the
bureaucracy it has to be trained and so
the real keystone of the administrative
state is the universe and the social
sciences that generate the kind of
knowledge that becomes defeated in terms
of how to understand these questions all
the social sciences are created at the
end of the 19th century and become part
of the way in which we think about this
problem so this is this is the difficult
yeah true um so we're probably as a
result of political forces at loose
moose in the country now to elect a
significant number of new
members of Congress will state
legislators who are concerned about the
growth of government and so my question
is you know what actually could they do
and I have two thoughts I'd be
interested in your reaction to ya one is
would it be make things better or worse
to require that Congress vote to approve
all of these regulations that come out
from the agencies and number two what do
you think of that nieces idea that
states ought to have the same power as
Congress to propose individual
amendments to the Constitution without
having to get the approval of Congress
well I think I'm not so sure that that
would I don't know what it would do I
don't know what his intention would be
in having that I don't think any of
these are procedural I don't think
there's any institutional way of
reforming the leads need the
institutions that would significantly
help I think what I think what you need
is is is a reconsideration of the way we
think about these problems and that that
requires a kind of education that goes
against everything that we have that
we're taught in our schools I mean the
real question is if it's not so clear
that people do want to be free if maybe
that they just want security in which
case this constitution is not made
simply for Pete for people that don't
want to be free I mean when you go back
when Madison says in federal 57 when
asked about what's going to happen if
Congress passes laws and exempts himself
from it Madison basically says well if
the people that the mainly spirit is he
causative America does not make them
rise up against a body that does that to
them then there's nothing you can do for
it they're willing to tolerate they're
willing to tolerate a kind of servitude
and thus think of what the administrator
state has done to buy off the various
constituencies and by the way this also
this health care bill I think points to
a possibility that that has not existed
before because when you look at the
health care bill as opposed to the way
in which the administrative state has
slowly kind of build itself by extending
privileges and extending subsidies to
various groups the cost of that were so
diffused that the general public really
was willing to bear the cost the
beneficiaries of course were
concentrated and the beneficiaries of
caught were for so all of the
beneficiaries of the administrative
state are happy with with the subsidies
they get and the general public is so
oblivious really until you what it costs
in terms of giving those subsidies that
it there's no sense in which the general
public is aware of the fact that there
are costs of the administrative state
but this health bill I think creates
this possibility for the first time it
seemed to me that in trying to extend
subsidies to a smaller maybe fifteen or
twenty percent uninsured they're
actually perhaps diminishing the choices
of a large people have already have
insurance and that was people once they
come to see that their choices are
actually being restricted people don't
mind getting benefits from the state but
they made mine they may mind when
they're when they don't have the choices
that they that they had so it's possible
I think to mobilize that sentiment that
this this majority of people that are
helped that are that are happy
their health care can be mobilized on
behalf of an opposition room to that
extension when you give particular kinds
of benefits that are not noticeable the
people except in this process has been
slow in terms of the 20th and 21st
century of extending benefits and
privileges and various other things but
there's most the great number of people
have not seen that there has there is a
cost for them so this time I think
they're they're going to see perhaps and
this is why I think they they structured
this bill the way they did so as to is
to minimize the effect of this for a
while but as I said I don't know how you
can deal in a structural way with the
loss of vigilance that people have to
have in order to retain control over
their cover I think you know I think
people now don't even think that their
rights are derived from anything but
government and so you know this whole
philosophy of that I've talked that I
talked about in the beginning of the
philosophy of nature and natural right
that provided the ground of this view of
freedom that that is receded so far into
the past and it's not even a memory for
most people most people are in however
you put it progresses progressives in
the sense that they believe in a
philosophy of his and not need this is
there's no unit that you this is the
education you get this is the authority
of science seems to rest on seems to
confirm this philosophy of history and
all of these things now make this is
problem much more difficult but I think
for before it can be solved it has to be
made intelligent I don't even think it's
intelligible to 22
Americans as in terms of a perspective
in terms of a conceptual framework if
you don't understand what we have become
as a result of this transformation then
it's very difficult to change it I would
say as a simple shorthand way of trying
to dis to to distill the two
philosophical conceptions of modern
politics beginning with the American
founders who really accepted the
doctrine of natural writing the doctors
of the philosophic tradition really
going back to the Greeks but but
certainly the political philosophy
articulated clearly by my law and that
is that the doctrine of natural right
really culminates in Constitution was
because it's based on nature it's based
on an understanding of human nature is
unchanging now that doctrine was being
attacked just about the time in the
American Founding by European thinkers
beginning with Russo but more
importantly I'll subsequently com Hagel
and those thinkers of course established
a philosophy of history would deny that
humans have an ache and they deny that
reason was a distinctive characteristic
of that nature they argued that passion
or will is the driving force of history
and that the culmination of this
historical process Hagel calls it the
matter of history is in the state itself
the vehicle of the state and so one
could say that the political movement of
philosophy of his culminates in the idea
of the state and the I mean the
political movement that accepts the idea
of the state is called progressivism so
there's a fundamental shift in the 19th
century after the Civil War and the
intellectuals in America really reject
it is a true of both liberals and
conservatives whether it's William
Graham Sumner or or the Socialists on
the other hand there is great clarity
that the intellectuals in the end of the
19th century rejected the doctrine of
constitutionalism and the doctrine of
natural right and when you look at the
the the establishment of the social
sciences in the period from roughly in
1880 on to 1910 orsa those all are
predicated on the assumption that that
philosophy of history is how it is that
we have to understand ourselves and and
the the social sciences in if one were
to look at this in a more theoretical
way they go in what you could say that
the social sciences are meant to be the
applied sciences of the state so you
know the American founders when they're
polluting when they talked about
political science they didn't talk about
Sciences the authority for politics they
talked about philosophy as the authority
for politics and so the people that they
look to were montesquieu and block and
cicero and Aristotle but when you look
at the way in which modern political
science and all the social sciences look
the authority for how we understand what
becomes meaningful knowledge is silent
and scientific Authority is really
formulate as the means to solve these
problems which is that the implicit
premise of the administrative state is
that individual human legislatures any
you and me we can't make these decisions
because you don't we don't have the
knowledge we don't have the technical
train that every decision is going to
have to be made every important decision
is going to require a certain kind of
knowledge that knowledge has to generate
it and it has to have some kind of
ability to be able to to utilize that
knowledge and so in I think about like
Knights labored will say by the 20th
century if the real power in the modern
in the modern state is in administration
the politicians are just Dylan tires
it's it's those who have the knowledge
that have the
and so this is this is part of the day
this is part of the difficulty is that
most people think and are that you know
that these problems ought to be solved
and maybe some of them often kick you
know some it's a matter of judgment or
proven system what it is that should be
solved and what it is that the people
themselves ought to do for themselves
but you know that the constitutional
system presupposes a distinction between
the public and the private sphere
between government civil society
presupposes that in civil society of
course there are contract there are
there is there there are consensual in
contractual ways in which people deal
with each other without force without
the necessity of government to impose or
in rules and and I am so that
fundamental that fundamental distinction
between the public and private sphere
which is crucial to constitutionalism in
other words there's a line apart beyond
which government cannot go I don't think
you can say any longer well I'll draw
the line here that government can't do
this is there any problem that you can
think of that if government doesn't want
it the government wants to do it that it
won't do it any problem come up with
anything that you can think of somebody
in Congress will come along and say we
should have a law to deal with that you
can't draw a line anymore between what
is public and private
yeah two different ways in Europe
they're protesting because they want to
make sure that the government ensures
that they can retire 50 years old sure
that the rest of their life of leisure
and Americans have the exact opposite
it's protest the government saying stop
doing to been doing leave us alone oh I
think I think there is this is the last
best hope I America does have a certain
spiritedness that you don't see those
countries of Europe have been in a
certain way dispirited throughout the
whole 20th century the two wars I think
and whatever else happened there made it
very difficult but I think but you see
when you think about it over the course
of the 19th and 20th century so many of
the people that came to America came
because they were seeking freedom and
opportunity so insofar yeah I think
America still is compared to most
people's very much driven by the desire
or production and work and even a
certain kind of freedom and so yeah I
would say that America is it is an
exception but it's an exception in many
ways when you think about because when I
said that the authority of history
philosophy of history destroyed me
destroyed the philosophic round of of
the understanding of America the
counterpart of that was also to destroy
the religious graph and and yet when one
looks at America one said you look at
polls and you see Americans believe in
God in numbers that in Europe think they
think these people are unsophisticated
fools over there you know 90
the people believe in God so the
religion and pop and philosophy that
authority that precedes scientific
Authority has not been fully undermined
in America and suddenly the I think yeah
America still has the spirit to be able
with the proper leadership to be
somebody has to tap it a mass can never
coalesce a mass needs a catalyst a mass
needs somebody to to bring it together
and it has somebody that knows what
they're doing I mean when you think of
the success of Ronald Reagan relative
success I mean there were a lot of
impossibilities but think about Reagan
never was able to serve with the house
in them in the Republican hand but he
mobilized at kissena me that in some
ways d legitimize liberalism for a
period of time so much so that they
would use in the name they went back to
progressivism they start calling
themselves progressive but they chose
you if just just using speech political
speech properly which so many of these
people the people on the Left know how
to do it they can mobilize political
speed but the people at the Republicans
and the leaders that should be able to
mobilize political speech on behalf of
freedom it's very there's much harder to
find them you'll note about Reagan to
that he was not one that came out of the
tradition of the universe and the elite
University were were that kind of
training or that kind of way of thinking
his knowledge of economics which he
learned at eureka college before
Keynesian theory stablished itself what
was sufficient was sufficient because it
was common sensical it was based on an
understanding of
kind of reality there's not imposed by
science or social science and so getting
out of the just just I think getting an
immobilizing political rhetoric which is
going to be very helpful if we could if
we but we need to get we need to train
people and how to think about these
questions I don't think we find except
for a few schools like Hillsdale there
aren't that many places where you can
get an education that can give you
confidence in the kinds of principles
and the kind of philosophical
theoretical understanding that enables
you to to go up against the
sophistication really of the modern
apparatus of the state both its
intellectual and its institutional form
all of the powers now and all the levers
are in the hands of those who have who
were defenders of the of the modern
state the state angle called it the
rational stick that's really a better
name because what he really meant was
that's the rule of organized
intelligence that's what the modern
state should be we call it the
administrative or welfare state but
that's just from the point of view of
what it does but not from the point of
view how to think about pinkles ways
better in terms of how to think about it
and of course we all benefit from
certain kinds of progress in science
Madison and all of them so progress in a
certain way we're all for right certain
kinds of product but the question is is
there progress beyond these principles
is their progress beyond the principles
of human quality and liberty understood
the way the founders did and if there is
no progress then of course there's no I
mean if there's no progress as a calvin
coolidge once put it
26 when he gave his famous speech on the
declaration says there is no progress on
the advance of that there's only you're
only going back the despot Issus forget
thank you very much okay thank you I
wish we did have time for more questions
but Professor marini will be able to
stick around for a few minutes if you do
have some more you can see from that
presentation why justice clarence thomas
credits both professor marini and
professor marinis colleague canvas oogie
for their assistance and in
understanding and shaping even his
judicial and political philosophy we're
grateful for professor Marinis talk you
can find it online we'll send that to
you by email so that you can share with
your friends and colleagues let me close
by inviting you to the next first
principles talk that will be held on the
first Friday of June June the fourth and
the next couple of weeks we'll see a
nomination come from the President of
the United States for a Supreme Court
justice to discuss that process and how
we ought to understand the role of the
judiciary is Ed Whelan a person who is
known to many in the the legal community
he is the president of the ethics and
Public Policy Center blogs regularly on
bench memos and will be speaking to a
very timely and important topic so that
will be on jun the fourth you'll get an
invite by email please do share that as
well with your friends neighbors and
colleagues thank you very much for
coming
you